DAN: WELCOME BACK TO
"UNFILTERED" MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE GETTING READY TO
FLY HOME OR FLY OUT HOME FOR THE
HOLIDAYS.
BUT BIG BROTHER COULD BE
WATCHING.
LIKE NEVER BEFORE --
THE TSA IS ROLLING OUT NEW
FACIAL RECOGNIZE SOFTWARE TO
REPLACE, YOU KNOW, PHOTO ID I
DON'T KNOW BUT THAT SOUNDS OUT
OF CHINA SURVEILLANCE STATE AND
WITH GOVERNMENT ABUSE A LOT CAN
GO WRONG AND NOT WILLING TO TAKE
THAT CHANCE AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR FORMER ANALYST.
BRET A LOT FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU KNOW BRET WHAT CONCERNS ME
ABOUT U.S. GOVERNMENT
IMPLEMENTING THIS IS THIS STUFF
HAS TO BE STORED SOMEWHERE AND
SHOWED NO IRS LEAKS OPM LEAKS AT
ALL TO SECURE INFORMATION NO
LESS FACIAL RECOGNITION.
>> XEANGT.
SO MUCH FOR PROTECT OUR FREEDOMS
I GUESS HERE DAN.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF MY FEAR
WE'RE GOING TO TURN INTO SAME
SURVEILLANCE CHINA HAS BECOME
AND IT IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
AND CHINA BEGAN USING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS TO BUILD A
SOCIAL CONTROL WHERE THEIR
SECURITY SERVICES NOW CAN JUST
PATROL ACROSS MULTIPLE DIGITAL
PLATFORMS TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
THOSE PEOPLE WORKING AGAINST THE
STATE AND SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE --
IS POTENTIALLY THE BEGINNING OF
AN UNPRECEDENTED STRANGLE HOLD
ON OUR SOCIETY WHEREBY
GOVERNMENT CAN CONTROL
EVERYTHING FROM POLITICS TO THE
ECONOMY --
TO EVEN PROTEST WITH
UNRESTRICTED ACCESS TO DATA THIS
IMPROVES SECURITY AND EFFICIENCY
AT AIRPORTS BUT WHAT IT IS
REALLY DOING IS BRINGING IN
UNPROVEN TECHNOLOGY WITH MASSIVE
CIVIL RIGHTS RAMIFICATIONS THAT
AS A SOCIETY WE REALLY YET TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT SECURITY
DAN YOU KNOW AIRLINES SHARE A
MATSIVE AMOUNT OF ENERGY AND
DATA WITH GOVERNMENT ON WHO IS
TRAVELING WHERE THEY'RE
TRAVELING, WHEN, SO WHY DO WE
NEED FACIAL RECOGNITION ALSO AND
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ORIGINS OF CHINA'S ARTIFICIAL
DEVELOPMENT YOU CAN SEE THAT --
PRESIDENT XI JINPING MOVED
FORWARD WITH THIS BELIEF THAT
WHOEVER CONTROLS A.I. CONTROLS
ENTIRE WORLD.
SO CHINA HAS SAID THE EXACT SAME
THING INITIALLY THAT TSA IS
SAYING HERE DEFENDING A.I. ABOUT
BRINGING SOME MORE FREEDOM
CONNECTING MORE CITIZENS.
BUT IN CHINA SO FAR ALL OF THAT
A.I. HAS DONE IS BROUGHT MORE
CONTROL.
>> YEAH BRET JUST A QUICK
RESPONSE AS I'M RUNNING OUT OF
TIME BUT TSA IS SCREWED UP LIKE
WITH THE FBI.
YOU KNOW THE DON'T FLY LIST --
I MEAN SO THE POTENTIAL FOR A,
YOU KNOW, CONFUSION HERE WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY IS PRETTY VAST.
JUST A QUICK THOUGHT ON THAT.
>> THINK ABOUT THE SECURITY
IMPLICATION CLAIMS IT IS
ENCRYPTED TO REDUCE HACKING RISK
AND ANY TIME BIG DATA IS STOLEN
WE CAN CHANGE OUR CREDIT CARDS
AND WE CAN CHANGE OUR LICENSES.
BUT YOU ONLY GET ONE FACE DAN,
AND IF YOU REMEMBER IN 2019 THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELANDS SECURITY
DISCLOSE THAT PHOTO OF TREAFERLS
THEY WERE TAKEN IN DATA BREACH
WHICH WAS ACCESS THROUGH NEXT OF
ONE OF ITS SUB CONTRACTORS THAT
WAS STORING THIS FACIAL
RECOGNITION DATA SO WE HAVEN'T
EXPLORED FULL ETHICS OF ALL OF
THIS WE'RE PUSHING BOUNDARIES OF
THAT RIGHT NOW.
I HOPE THAT TSA KNOW WHAT IS
THEY'RE DOING WITH THIS DATA AND
NO MISUSE INVOLVED.
DAN: ME TOO.
TH